kitchen staff at restless glücklich in
Berlin are preparing for the next day
this restaurant is all about creativity
because the food they use was destined
for the garbage ingredients today
include cauliflower and carrots head
chef Daniel Reich has already mastered
several challenges man conocer mas mahal
he ganson bled hola you can make
something from anything even from the
green part of a carrot like a salad or
smoothie we made a dish using only
kohlrabi leaves cool hobby but on
another day we made a curry from
cauliflower leaves so we really make use
of everything others as I ain't I forgot
my phasellus the two chefs are the only
paid employees at rest los glücklich the
others are all volunteers from an
organization that runs the restaurant
the idea came from environmental
scientist aneta coil and training
manager Leone Beckman after they visited
a similar restaurant in Denmark the
Mishnah and / afters problem now we
wanted to raise awareness about food
wastage by doing something nice yes by
providing meals that's in my water is so
encouraging when we serve the food
people are often amazed they understand
what a shame it would have been to throw
the food away that's the roads i
initiate it always has a profound effect
on people besides only my neck or severe
combined enliven at this organic
supermarket in berlin anything that's
not completely fresh or perfectly shaped
is simply thrown away the restaurant
goes to pick up the rejected food twice
a week a lot of people demand immaculate
fresh produce but there are consequences
18 million tons of the food flown into
Germany every year ends up in the trash
even though around half is perfectly
edible man smile Reza's but sometimes it
makes me quite angry yeah
because there are so many hungry people
in the world you can do something with
all this food and as far as I'm
concerned the surplus shouldn't exist
waste is detrimental to the environment
the restaurant always tries to create
sophisticated dishes with the food it's
salvages the meals are almost always
vegetarian and cost between six and nine
euros profits go towards cooking classes
for adults and workshops in schools
always centered around the topic of
waste prevention as a hard-fought shaft
is our main messages trust your senses
don't get fixated on sell by dates and
after we can just look at it what is the
food and is it still edible does not
good news for you can open a yogurts and
try it they're still fine to eat weeks
after the sell-by date has passed he
needs power and you don't have to throw
it out the date supposedly goes off I'm
had the a bluff in ruins are another
evening begins tonight the kitchen staff
have whipped up a risotto with chard and
beetroot also on offer lettuce soup and
wheat crackers and for dessert sweet
lemon dumplings with a chocolate pepper
sauce the menu is a hit with the guests
as yes sir let chemistry I thought it
was really delicious it's like proper
home cooking it tasted really really
good Richmond does Agnes can school does
this I think it's great that the food
doesn't just get thrown away it gets put
to good use and prevents waste fresh
very useful
since it was founded wrestlers look lish
has already won five awards good to see
their efforts haven't gone unnoticed